was wäre ihrer meinung nach die coolste
superkraft für mich wäre es glaube ich
die zeit kontrollieren zu können
langweilige stellen im leben einfach mal
vorspulen wenn man verschlafen hat ab
und an mal die zeit anhalten um schlaf
nachholen zu können
und wenn irgendwas richtig schief
gegangen ist einfach mal zwei drei
stunden zurück springen und alles wieder
in ordnung bringen
aber das ist beinahe unmöglich wenn man
nicht gerade mit annähernd
lichtgeschwindigkeit reisen kann oder
starke gravitation nur für sich selber
erzeugen könnte aber auf dem zweiten
platz knapp dahinter ist für mich
gedankenlesen und manipulieren können
und ob es glaubt oder nicht im gegensatz
zu zeitreisen scheint gedankenlesen
schon beinahe realität zu sein
dieses video ist zusammen mit mats vom
kanalnetz denkt entstanden ich glaube
viele von euch kennen ihn
gegen ihn habe ich am anfang des videos
poker gespielt wir machen beide videos
zum thema gedanken lesen hier auf meinem
kanal geht es mir um die technische
umsetzung und ob gedanken lesen
überhaupt möglich sein kann und bei max
geht es dann um die moralischen folgen
dieser technik wer darf so etwas
überhaupt benutzen und was könnte man
damit alles gutes oder böses anstellen
mega spannende fragen die mazda aufwirft
aber bis es soweit kommt müssen wir erst
mal klären wie so etwas überhaupt
funktionieren könnte schon mal vorneweg
wenn ihr beim pokerspielen die gedanken
eures gegners lesen wollt dann könnt ihr
das glaube ich erst mal vergessen denn
unauffällig sind die geräte die dafür
benutzt werden definitiv nicht
fm scanner messen die gehirnaktivität
und den blutkreislauf im gehirn von
menschen sie werden benutzt um
verletzungen zu untersuchen und um das
gehirn zu erforschen und breit 2008
haben japanische wissenschaftler in
einem experiment das erste mal versuchte
die gedanken von jemandem zu
entschlüsseln
das experiment mit ungefähr so ab den
testpersonen wurden verschiedene schwarz
weiß bilder von buchstaben gezeigt und
während sie die bilder anzahl wurde die
gehirnaktivität gemessen
die wissenschaftler konnten dann
beobachten welche gehirnströme
ausgesendet wurden als die teilnehmer
die bilder gesehen haben also wie das
gehirn mit diesen neuen informationen
umgegangen ist
mit diesen daten versuchen die forscher
das gehirn besser zu verstehen und
können mit ein paar algorithmen in einem
zweiten test versuchen die bilder aus
den gehirnströmen wiederherzustellen
und siehe da man kann eventuell mit
vielen glück lesen was da steht
eine andere gruppe von forschern führte
das experiment weiter und zeigte den
teilnehmern im scanner youtube-videos
wieder wurde die gehirnaktivität
gemessen und der computer interpretierte
die daten
das ergebnis ist irgendwie surreal und
vielleicht auch etwas kritik aber man
kann auch erkennen dass es gar nicht so
falsch ist ein weiterer algorithmus
versuchte dann die computer
interpretation mit tausenden von youtube
clips zu vergleichen und sie zuzuweisen
die ergebnisse sind zugegebenermaßen
noch nicht das was man wirklich gedanken
lesen nennen könnte aber wie so oft
steht am anfang einer großen idee
erstmal nur ein rudimentäres konzept und
dieses konzept funktioniert definitiv
die wissenschaftler gehen sogar davon
aus dass man ihn vielleicht 20 jahren
seine träume aufzeichnen könnte um sie
sich später noch mal anzusehen
das wäre ziemlich krass wenn man mal
darüber nachdenkt dass unser
unterbewusstsein viele erfahrungen und
emotionen im schlaf verarbeitet wie aber
90 prozent unserer träume schon zehn
minuten nach dem aufwachen vergessen
haben steckt auch gerade jemand daran
dass diese tolle revolutionäre technik
dann dazu missbraucht wird seine
kühnsten träume auf facebook zu teilen
oder welches netzwerk auch immer in 20
oder 30 jahren
cool ist aber natürlich gibt es auch
wesentlich sinnvollere anwendungen für
diese bahnbrechende technik menschen die
im koma liegen oder ganz körper gelähmt
sind können zu ihrem körper nicht mehr
kontrollieren sind aber dennoch bei
bewusstsein und ihre sinne funktionieren
oft ohne probleme man könnte mit diesen
menschen endlich wieder kommunizieren
sie von ihrer jahrelangen einsamkeit
befreien
ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen wie
schrecklich es sein muss in seinem
eigenen körper gefangen zu sein und das
für jahre
aber wenn wir schon bei kommunikationen
sind mit einer ähnlichen technik wurde
bereits vor zwei jahren das erste mal
ein direktes gehirn zu gehirn gespräch
geführt und zwar über das internet was
der eine mensch dachte kamen beim
anderen an
auch hier klar befindet sich die technik
noch ganz am anfang aber wenn ich jetzt
sage dass wir in 30 jahren das neue
facebook vielleicht gar nicht mehr auf
dem smartphone sondern im kopf haben
klinge ich gar nicht mehr so verrückt
oder aber mit großem technischen
fortschritt geht auch schnell die
überwachungs frage einher
wenn diese technik wirklich bereit für
den consumer markt wird sollte man sie
dann überhaupt zulassen könnte man diese
technik nicht viel zu leicht
missbrauchen und jeder könnte unsere
gedanken überwachen
man sollte die polizei gedankenlesen
benutzen dürfen um wichtige
informationen und geständnisse aus
verdächtigen zu erhalten viele spannende
und mega interessante fragen und wie am
anfang angekündigt setzt sich matz von
jetzt denkt damit wunderbar auseinander
klicke jetzt hier oben auf das sie und
schaut euch ein video an wo ich einen
kriminellen bombenleger spiele viel spaß
was sagt ihr dazu denkt ihr dass diese
technik die zukunft ist mit der wir
irgendwann alle kommunizieren werden
gibt es vielleicht ein internet das nur
aus gehirn besteht und jeder
kommuniziert einfach nur per
gedankenkraft oder habt ihr angst um
ihre geistige freiheit schreibt sie
unten in die kommentare
ich bin wirklich gespannt mit euch
darüber diskutieren zu können weil ich
glaube dass vielleicht bald ein sehr
relevantes thema wird schreibt auf jeden
fall auch was nettes video irgendwie
haben den ziemlich coole kollaboration
gemacht und es hat mir wirklich viel
spaß gemacht ich bin jetzt erstmal raus